En sciences, quand une théorie est à la fois simple et claire
et quand elle fait des prédictions plus justes que n'importe quelle autre théorie
y compris notre intuition,
alors il faut avoir davantage confiance en la théorie en question
plutôt qu'en les autres théories que notre intuition pourrait imaginer.
Et ce, même si la théorie en question
est super contre-intuitive.
Sur Science4All on en a vu des théories contre-intuitives :
De la géométrie hyperbolique où le théorème de Pythagore est faux
au principe d'équivalence d'Einstein qui dit que le sol accélère vers le haut
en passant par la logique intuitionniste
où certains ensembles ne sont ni finis ni infinis.
Aujourd'hui ce dont on va parler c'est de la meilleure théorie dont les sciences disposent
de la politique.
Cette théorie est si performante
que le professeur Bruce Bueno de Mesquita
s'est appuyé dessus pour écrire un algorithme
qui prend en compte des données fournies par des experts
pour effectuer des prédictions régulièrement achetées par les PDG des grandes entreprises
et les agences de sécurité type NSA.
De façon stupéfiante,
l'algorithme fait de meilleures prédictions
que les experts qui en ont fourni les données
Et ça ça montre bien que le modèle de Mesquita n'exploite pas des données que les experts n'ont pas.
Si le modèle de la politique selon Mesquita est plus performant pour faire des prédictions,
c'est uniquement parce que sa logique et ses postulats sont plus valides
que la manière dont même les experts
pensent la politique.
Dit autrement, le principe fondamental de la politique selon Mesquita
est scientifiquement beaucoup plus fiable
que ce que chacun d'entre nous pourrait penser comprendre de la politique.
Et ce, peu importe à quel point ce principe fondamental
est contre-intuitif.
Alors, ce principe fondamental c'est quoi ?
Eh bien, pour le comprendre,
je vous propose de parler de l'un des personnage les plus mystérieux de l'histoire de l'humanité :
Le roi Leopold II de Belgique
Le bon vieux roi Leopold II de Belgique :
Roi aimé de tous,
il construit tellement de trucs BG qu'on le surnomme le roi bâtisseur.
Il met en place l'éducation gratuite obligatoire
autorise les ouvriers à se réunir en syndicats
a interdit le travail pour les enfants de moins de 12 ans
et instaure le vote au suffrage universel.
Leopold II est donc très certainement un des meilleurs rois de l'histoire.
Les Belges l'adorent.
Sauf que pendant ce temps...
Leopold II était aussi le roi du Congo.
Au Congo, ce fut un carnage.
Les militaires maltraitaient la population et y régnaient en maîtres absolus.
Le bilan de tout ça ?
Environ 10 millions de morts,
à confirmer.
Soit autant voire plus que durant l'holocauste 40 ans plus tard.
Oui, vous l'avez bien compris :
Le meilleur roi de l'histoire de la Belgique
est aussi l'auteur d'un génocide comparable
à l'extermination des juifs par Hitler pendant la Seconde Guerre Mondiale.
Comment un même individu peut-il avoir été autant adulé et détesté ?
Comment une même personne a pu être si philanthropique et criminelle ?
Comment un homme a pu être si bienfaiteur et démoniaque ?
Pour Mesquita, toutes ces questions sont à côté de la plaque.
Selon son principe fondamental de la politique,
un homme au pouvoir n'est ni gentil ni méchant,
il n'est ni bienveillant ni malveillant,
il n'est ni charitable ni machiavélique.
Pour Mesquita, tout ce qu'un homme politique souhaite c'est être et rester au pouvoir.
Qu'il soit mère Thérésa ou la tête pensante d'une organisation terroriste extrêmiste,
qu'il soit le dictateur d'un régime autoritaire ou le président d'une république démocratique,
qu'il soit le chef d'une institution publique ou le PDG d'une firme multinationale,
les désirs, convictions, religions, cultures et volontés importent peu.
Ce qui importe, c'est accéder au pouvoir et y rester durablement.
Tel est le principe fondamental de la politique selon Mesquita,
et ce n'est pas le politicien Jim Manley, interviewé par John Oliver,
qui contredira ce principe fondamental.
Mais pourquoi donc ?
Pourquoi les hommes politiques serait-ils si obsédés par le pouvoir ?
Est-ce parce que les hommes politiques ont tous suivi le même conditionnement... euh je voulais dire... la même éducation ?
ça joue sans doute.
Mais il y a une explication beaucoup plus simple :
La politique est un jeu entre politiciens.
Et les politiciens qui passent beaucoup de temps à étudier les sciences
pour ensuite améliorer les conditions de vie du peuple
ont plusieurs longueurs de retard
sur ceux qui veulent juste gagner au Game of Thrones.
Quand le trône attise la convoitise,
la compétition est rude
et les politiciens qui accéderont et resteront au pouvoir
seront ceux qui auront fait ce qu'il fallait pour y accéder
et qui font ce qu'il faut pour y rester.
Tel est le grand jeu de la politique.
Et si le roi Leopold II a marqué l'Histoire en restant au pouvoir aussi longtemps
en Belgique et au Congo
c'est parce qu'il avait parfaitement compris
les règles du jeu de la politique.
Au Congo, les forces militaires étaient une source de pouvoir majeure.
Pour ne pas se faire renverser par ses forces armées,
le roi Leopold II devait instituer un système qui les enrichit
Par chance pour Leopold,
le Congo disposait d'une richesse naturelle : le caoutchouc.
A une époque où l'industrie des bicyclettes et des voitures était en train d'émerger grâce à cette matière première,
Leopold II savait que récolter ce caoutchouc le rendrait riche.
L'argent du caoutchouc pourrait ensuite être partiellement redistribué à ses généraux militaires,
ce qui les satisferait et leur donnerait une bonne raison de ne pas tenter de coup d'état.
Mais pour assurer un flot permanent de richesse pour ses généraux,
Leopold devait forcer son peuple à exploiter les ressources naturelles de leur pays
et s'assurer que ce peuple reverserait la quasi-totalité de ces ressources à Leopold lui-même.
Pour garantir la taxation quasi-totale de son peuple,
Leopold se devait d'être dur avec lui.
Il devait encourager les militaires à exterminer tous ceux qui pourraient être réfractaires
à la taxation drastique de Leopold II.
Pour être et rester au pouvoir,
Leopold devait violemment oppresser, torturer et exterminer le peuple congolais
et Leopold a violemment oppressé, torturé et exterminé le peuple Congolais.
Au Congo, Leopold fut un des rois les plus criminels et les plus meurtriers de l'Histoire.
Mais en Belgique ?
En Belgique, la démocratisation des technologies et de la richesse
a remis en question son autorité.
Pour rester au pouvoir,
Leopold II se devait d'anticiper l'émancipation inéluctable de son peuple
et lui céder ainsi du pouvoir avant que celui-ci ne le renverse.
Mieux encore, à une époque où les industries lourdes naissantes nécessitaient une main d'oeuvre qualifiée
la majeure partie de la richesse du pays s'était transférée des ressources naturelles
au capital humain.
Pour produire plus, pour produire mieux
et pour avoir plus de richesses à redistribuer aux autres individus et institutions gouvernant la Belgique,
Leopold II avait tout intérêt à investir dans le capital humain.
Il avait tout intérêt à investir dans une éducation gratuite et obligatoire pour tous les enfants belges.
Il avait tout intérêt à autoriser les ouvriers des entreprises
à se réunir en syndicats pour éviter toute émeute de leur part.
Il avait même intérêt à instaurer un vote au suffrage universel
parce que des citoyens plus éduqués, plus organisés et plus impliqués politiquement
étaient des citoyens plus entreprenants, plus productifs et produisant plus de richesse
que Leopold pourra réinvestir dans des biens publics
pour davantage gagner le cœur de ceux qu'il gouverne
et les amener à le préférer à de potentiels présidents et ministres élus pour gouverner la Belgique à sa place.
Pour être et rester au pouvoir,
Leopold avait tout intérêt à améliorer les conditions de vie de son peuple Belge
et Leopold a amélioré les conditions de vie de son peuple Belge.
Un homme politique n'est pas bon ou mauvais.
Un homme politique analyse toutes ses options
et choisit celle(s) qui maximise(nt) ses chances d'être et de rester au pouvoir.
Du coup, ce qui fait que l'homme politique fera quelque chose de bon ou de mauvais
n'est pas l'homme politique lui-même.
Ce qui fait qu'un homme politique fera quelque chose de bon ou de mauvais,
ce sont les incitatifs ou incentives qui lui sont donnés.
En particulier, si la richesse d'un pays dépend essentiellement de l'exploitation d'une ressource naturelle,
alors les dirigeants de ce pays oppresseront le peuple.
Et ce ne sera pas alors parce que les hommes au pouvoir seront des psychopathes corrompus par le pouvoir,
ce sera parce que, pour ne pas se faire renverser par leurs rivaux,
les hommes au pouvoir devront agir en dictateurs autoritaires
et devront oppresser leur peuple.
Si c'est en faisant le mal qu'un homme politique pourra être et rester au pouvoir,
alors il fera le mal.
Mais à l'inverse, si étant donné le contexte socio-économique
et les positions idéologiques de ses suporters
un homme politique devra faire le bien pour être et rester au pouvoir,
alors il fera le bien.
Tel est le principe fondamental de la politique selon Mesquita :
Tout homme politique veut être et rester au pouvoir.
Et je le répète : Ce principe fondamental est au fondement de la meilleure théorie scientifique que l'on a de la politique
et les prédictions de cette théorie sont plus justes que les prédictions des experts.
Elles seront donc aussi forcément beaucoup plus fiables
que chacun de mes avis personnels et que chacun de vos avis.
En bons scientifiques il nous faut préférer penser selon la logique de ce modèle de la politique
plutôt que selon notre intuition et nos avis.
Et ça, ça veut dire qu'en particulier
il faut prendre très aux sérieux les conséquences très contre-intuitives de ce principe fondamental de la politique.
Numéro 1 : Ce que les hommes politiques pensent vraiment importe peu.
C'est pour ça que je censure vos messages sur les hommes politiques.
Certes les hommes politiques diffèrent dans les réseaux d'influence qu'ils possèdent et subissent,
et dans leur capacité à convaincre d'autres à se rallier à leur cause
mais ce qu'ils pensent vraiment n'importe pas.
Ce qui importe ce sont les autres politiciens, les lobbys et les électeurs envers lesquels ils sont redevables
et sans lesquels ils ne pourront pas être et rester au pouvoir.
Numéro 2: les concepts de mérite et de responsabilité des hommes politiques sont inutiles
pour analyser, comprendre et prédire la politique.
Les hommes politiques ne réagissent pas à la responsabilité ou au mérite
ils réagissent uniquement aux incentives,
c'est à dire à ce qui pourrait remettre en cause leur stratégie pour être et rester au pouvoir.
Alors ça ne veut pas dire que ça ne sert à rien de critiquer leurs positions idéologiques.
Après tout, notamment en démocratie, si le peuple menace le pouvoir d'un homme politique,
parce qu'il dit de lui qu'il ne mérite pas son poste ou qu'il est irresponsable,
alors, pour être et rester au pouvoir,
l'homme politique pourrait avoir intérêt à davantage suivre l'avis du peuple
plutôt que celui des lobbys.
Mais du coup, ce qui importe là c'est davantage la perception
du mérite et de la responsabilité des hommes politiques selon le peuple
et en tout cas ce n'est pas la perception du mérite et de la responsabilité selon les politiciens
ni d'ailleurs selon moi.
Numéro 3 : Les hommes politiques ne sont pas stupides.
Si ils étaient stupides ils auraient perdu au jeu de la politique
et on n'aurait jamais entendu parler d'eux.
Bien entendu ils ne sont pas omniscients non plus.
Après tout, le modèle de la politique selon Mesquita
surpasse les capacités cognitives de même les experts de la politique
et nécessite des calculs par ordinateur.
Mais ce que je veux dire par là, c'est que les politiciens sont bien plus malins
que ce que l'on dit si souvent d'eux.
Si on en vient à croire qu'ils sont stupides
c'est parce qu'on en a une vision stigmatisée, exagérée et caricaturée
et parce que l'on comprend mal les incentives qui leur sont imposées.
Et ce n'est pas surprenant que l'on comprenne mal leurs incentives.
Après tout, il arrive souvent qu'il soit dans l'intérêt des hommes politiques
de garder secrètes et confidentielles
les alliances politiques qui les lient à d'autres hommes politiques ou à d'autres organismes.
Numéro 4 : Avoir raison ne sert à rien en politique.
Il me semble que trop souvent quand on parle de politique on se demande qui a raison.
Mais avoir raison, les hommes politiques s'en moquent complètement !
Ce n'est pas en ayant raison qu'ils accéderont au pouvoir et y resteront.
Ce qui importe pour le politicien,
c'est que les autres hommes politiques, les industriels et l'électorat
leur donnent raison.
Et ça, c'est vraiment pas la même chose.
Pour gagner une élection, les politiciens ont bien plus intérêt
à concevoir, diffuser et défendre des convictions semblables à celles dont on a parlé dans l'épisode précédent
qu'à se fonder sur des théories empiriques et des données axiomatiques.
Numéro 5 : Avant de vous lancer en politique pour changer le monde,
réfléchissez-y à 2 fois.
Certes, sans pouvoir vous ne pourrez rien changer.
Mais l'accession au pouvoir exigera certainement de vous que vous abandonniez certaines de vos convictions.
Non pas parce que vos idées sont mauvaises,
mais parce qu'il y a de bonnes chances que les autres politiciens, les personnes d'influence et l'électorat
ne vous donnent pas raison.
En particulier, les politiciens n'ont pas besoin d'idées nouvelles.
Les politiciens ont besoin d'idées qui plaisent aux autres politiciens, aux personnes d'influence et à l'électorat.
Numéro 6 : Quand vous irez voter dimanche, ne vous demandez pas pour "qui" vous voulez voter.
Demandez-vous plutôt quels sont les incentives que vous voulez imposer au futur président de la république.
Demandez-vous si, pour être et rester au pouvoir,
l'homme politique en question aura intérêt à appliquer le programme qu'il a promis
et s'il y a des choses qu'il n'a pas promis de faire mais qu'il aura intérêt à faire enfin au pouvoir.
En particulier, ne votez pas pour des personnes.
Ne votez pas pour des valeurs non plus.
Ne votez pas pour des idées.
Votez pour les incentives qui incomberont notre prochain président de la République.
La dernière fois on a parlé des convictions et TheAnat001 sent qu'il y avait une influence de CGP Grey dans la vidéo précédente
Tout à fait. En fait le fond de la vidéo précédente est ultra inspiré de la vidéo "This video will make you angry"
Et la forme a été aussi largement inspirée de "Rules for Rulers"
qui est la vidéo de CGP Grey qui parle de Bruce Bruno de Mesquita
Je recommande ultra vivement cette vidéo. Pour moi la politique n'a de sens que si l'on réfléchit dans des modèles à la Mesquita
Et c'est ce que présente très bien CGP Grey
Cette vidéo je vous conseille vraiment de la voir, de la revoir et de la re-revoir
Personnellement j'ai dû la voir une dizaine de fois
Et j'ai l'impression que chaque fois que je la regarde j'apprends encore un peu mieux à penser selon la logique du modèle de Mesquita
Nicola Larroque semble avoir apprécié le fond de la vidéo précédente mais critique la forme
Et vu le nombre de likes qu'a ce commentaire, je pense qu'il y en a pas mal parmi vous qui ont été mal à l'aise vis à vis du ton, de la musique que j'ai employés dans la vidéo précédente
Si vous n'avez pas aimé je m'en excuse. J'explore aussi différents styles.
Je dois bien dire que personnellement ça m'a fait ultra triper de faire une vidéo dans ce genre, de me tester sur un autre style
De voir que je pouvais avoir un truc qui ressemblait un tout petit peu, au moins à CGP Grey.
Je pense que sous-jacent à ce commentaire et à d'autres commentaires de la vidéo précédente,
Il semblerait que j'ai donné l'impression dans la vidéo précédente que les convictions c'était forcément quelque chose de mal ou de pas souhaitable
C'est pas du tout l'objectif de la vidéo précédente.
L'objectif de la vidéo précédente était uniquement descriptif
J'essayais de décrire quelles étaient les conséquences, notamment des nouvelles technologies sur la manière dont les convictions se forment, se propagent ou se diffusent
Et je pense aussi que la diffusion des sciences et du savoir doit s'adapter à la manière dont les convictions se propagent à travers internet
Et je ne pense pas que ce soit une mauvaise chose
Je pense que les mathématiques sont vivantes une fois qu'on leur attribue des émotions
Moi personnellement j'ai été atterré par le théorème de la d'impensabilité d'Arrow
Je suis intrigué par les ordinateurs quantiques, le fait qu'ils sont capables de casser la cryptographie qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
Et j'ai été absolument heureux quand j'ai découvert le scrutin de Condorcet randomisé
Et c'est pour ça que j'adore les mathématiques
C'est pas parce que ça rend rationnel, ça aide à réfléchir et tout ça
Ca j'ai envie de dire que c'est un effet secondaire, une espèce de side-effect, du fait d'apprendre les mathématiques, qui est souhaitable
Mais ce n'est pas la raison première pour laquelle je trouve les mathématiques
fascinantes et c'est pas la raison pour laquelle je passe autant de temps à lire, à penser et si possible créer des mathématiques
Et je pense que c'est quelque chose qui manque énormément dans la communication
des sciences en général et des mathématiques en particulier
C'est cet aspect émotif
Et notamment la fascination que les mathématiques peuvent provoquer
parce que à la réponse : Comment fait-on pour lutter contre les mauvaises convictions ?
Bah j'ai envie de dire que la seule solution c'est de développer un esprit critique et cet esprit critique, il faut vouloir le développer